a year of Darkness for Isaac's mom Lisa
he was just a typical 13 year old boy
had some good group of friends
very loving
Lisa thinks social media might hold the
clues to what drove Isaac to his death
last year
we have this mission for every other
parent that's been going through this
to either come forward or know they've
got support
and also
to
really push forward to get some
awareness about these social platforms
that things need to be stepped up
that push needs strong backing Lisa
found that among other bereaved families
Liam Walsh whose daughter Maya died last
year
the question I asked as I ran my fingers
through her hair and I held her belly
was what has happened Maya
what has happened to you
and I'm asked I'm still asking that
question today
the families have come together to raise
awareness they want to make sure online
history is always considered when
determining why a child takes their own
life either by accident or intentionally
they met at the home of George and
aretti who still can't grasp what
happened to their son christophores
at 9 15 approximately came down and said
dad can I go and play and as his team
yes of course you can son for a little
while and that was the last
that was uh that was the end
you're right yeah
there is some comfort in meeting the
father of Molly Russell
last year a coroner ruled Molly died not
by Suicide but as a result of self-harm
while depressed and exposed to the
negative effects of online content I
think having Molly's Dad here
is given us knowledge that we didn't
know opened our eyes to a few things
that we can potentially do and use
moving forward
Ian Russell says the tragedy of his
daughter's death played out against a
backdrop of poorly regulated social
media platforms it must not he says be
repeated
these families have made it their
mission to make sure of that Sadia
Chaudhary Sky News
now if you or anyone you know have been
affected by the content of that story
please remember that you can call the
Samaritans on
116-123 or you can email Joe that's Joe
at samaritans.org